what are the five resources that you
need to consume to be a great
entrepreneur I'm gonna answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so I'm in the process of acquiring
a new business and as a part of that
I've brought on a new director of
operations to run the business because
I'm too busy doing this other stuff
right making these videos for you guys
and so part of my role is to mentor him
to be an entrepreneur to think like an
entrepreneur to run a business and to
grow it and so I was sitting down with
him yesterday sharing some of the
resources that I think you should go
over and I thought that's a pretty cool
list I think I should share it with my
YouTube audience too and hopefully they
could benefit so I'm gonna share with
you guys today and I'm curious to know
what you guys think number one is the
profit this is a TV show that's on CNBC
and it's with a successful entrepreneur
named Marcus lemonis who goes and
invests in businesses he's invited in by
an entrepreneur who's struggling who
wants to grow and he'll put his own
money in and he has a mantra of people
passion and process and it's really
interesting to see how he looks at a new
business and then how he makes immediate
changes to make that business better and
you can't help but learn and think about
how can I make my business better in
each episode that comes out so it's a
really cool show I recommend you check
it out number two is a website called
which test one and what this is is a
collection of all sorts of different
marketing tests that people have done
testing one headline versus another one
call to action button versus another one
homepage design versus another and helps
really increase your IQ for online
marketing because we're going to be
doing a lot of online marketing in this
business this new director of operations
needs to up his game and so what I find
really helpful is they have a weekly
newsletter and you get an email update
every week it's totally free and what's
cool about it is they'll show you the
two sides they'll show you the two
headlines or the two website layouts
face to face and you have to pick to see
which one you think converts better it's
all about converting which one converts
better and only after you pick does it
actually give you the data to show which
one one
so it's which test one calm and it's a
really cool site number three is gary
vaynerchuk's youtube channel gary is
pretty much the only channel that i
watched consistently to get business
ideas and insights he focuses a lot on
social media and having success in a
digital economy but also talks about
entrepreneurship in general and hiring
and leading and building teams and
creating products and he's got our show
called the askgaryvee show that is out
once to a couple of times per week
Beauty about 20 minutes long and a lot
of times on YouTube I find myself
multitasking I'm trying to you know
watch a video while doing something else
and I find with Gary's videos I can't
multitask because he says something that
I have to think about and I end up
having to pause and rewind and come back
to and come back to it so definitely
worth checking out side question of the
day do you guys multitask while watching
my videos leave it below I want to know
number four is the book joy Inc I'm not
sure if I've talked about it before in
this channel or not but it's about how
to build a business around joy around
the concept of joy and it's put out by a
company that I went to see not too long
ago in Ann Arbor Michigan called Menlo
innovations and they've built the six
million dollar business without having a
sales team all by building a culture of
joy and this business has his own one
word that we're building a business
around and so it's basically taking that
book and applying all of those concepts
to our one word instead of joy it's
something else and so if you're trying
to build the business around one word
like I've done with believe you want to
find your own one word then that's a
great kind of how-to handbook that he's
got to pick up and read I think it
helped you guys too and number five this
might sound super self-serving but it's
my channel and you know I created
specifically the N special Series in the
top ten series
selfishly because I wanted to learn
because I loved the content that that
we're breaking and even if you don't
watch the luncheon earns or any other
content the N spresso and the top ten
series is learning from successful
entrepreneurs who've done it who have
wisdom who have creativity who have
insight
that will help make you the best version
of yourself and the best entrepreneur
check video in the channel but I think
those two series in particular will
really help make you better entrepreneur
and I recommended them to him as well
so those are my top five resources I
hope you check them out and enjoy them
I'd love to know what your favorite
resources are maybe with something new
for me to learn to leave it in the
comments below and I'll check them out
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon